luis castillo it's the back half that's
been really sterling
well it's the it's the velocity it's the
movement
look for him to establish that fastball
early go to the breaking ball
and it hasn't been just the change-up
we've seen him
profiling a very nice slider as well
castillo's first 10 starts the aggregate
numbers
were horrendous his last 10 starts he
has been
sensational dylan carlson leads it off
at the knees 98 looking
i mean look at the movement 98 mile an
hour look at the movement on this pitch
paul goldschmidt and the 1-0
lined at a base head he's now been on
base 21
straight games and hitting well above
350 in those 21 games
simplifies thing on this it's 98 mile an
hour sinker
starts over the middle tails in and just
shoots it the other way
nolan orenado double play ball
farmer india one giddy up
the 4-3 inning double play
and we head to the bottom of the first
jake woodford getting the call tonight
for st
louis beat the cubs at bush that was
monday night
one run and five and two-thirds and he
looked very good he used two different
fastballs the fourth seam and the two
seam
goes with the curve ball quite a bit
against the left the slider
uses him more to the right he's in every
once in a while he'll mix in that change
up
winker with the base heading to right
good quick hands there by dylan carlson
that got on him in a hurry
so walking now is single and it brings
in vato 2-2
tails backhand and a strikeout perfectly
located pitch by jake woodford
goes fastball front door tails it back
right on the corner
tyler naquin naked
carlson's arm was shown yesterday stop
sign at third
fire in cut off by goldschmidt that was
a good decision
tyler naquin hits this ball hard and it
gets the crossing
fairly quickly and you can see the angle
that he has
coming up in india running with his head
up one strike bases loaded two outs
the pitch to farmer he swings and he
pops it up
short right field second baseman tommy
edmond is under it he has it
and the bases remain loaded runners hit
first
and second for harrison bader vader
swings and hits it hard left field to
base it
coming around third base trying to score
paul de young the throw
is way off line one nothing cardinals
harrison bader drives in his 21st run
the wade de young rounded third base
ricky it was like
he thought he might be held up but pop
warner was there like a windmill waving
him around
with the throw from winker way off line
and there's the difference between
having an outfielder with a plus arm and
having an outfielder with a
below average arm got a piece
barnhart holds on cardinals take the
lead
but the cardinals scored a run and we go
to the bottom of the second one nothing
st
louis jesse winker has singled to right
and weaker goes up onto the gap that's
open
all the way to the wall akiyama scores
india rounds third
he's gonna score a two-run standing
double
and jesse winker delivers a lead for the
reds
2-1 base hit by jonathan india and then
jesse winker does what jesse winker does
now joey votto struck out looking first
time up
and hits that to goldschmidt he'll take
it himself
but the damage was done with two outs
the o2 pitch
edmond hits it the other way it is well
hit
and that ball is down one hopper off the
wall
and de young on his way to third trying
to go
inside this ends up being up and away
and tommy shoots it right in the gap
it's a good job being on that pitch
payoff
swing in the middle struck him out that
ball never started out as a strike and
just a very aggressive swing from an
aggressive player
castillo delivers swing in the miss
fastball
strike three joey vado first pitch high
fly
deep left tyler o'neill bends back and
it's gone
oppo votto expands the lead
swing in the bat with some bad intention
getting extended on a high fastball
the pitcher already supplied the
elevation all you got to do is touch it
and touch it he did castillo pitching
into the sixth inning for an 11th
consecutive start elevates on the young
swing and miss seven strikeouts for luis
castillo
climb the ladder castillo has been
working ahead of so many batters tonight
strike three called got him looking
right over the inside corner
edmond punched out give him eight
strikeouts luis castillo
is dialed in luis castillo still on that
bump he's had a quality start in six of
seven
he's gone seven innings four times this
year
three since the middle of june apiece
foul tip nine strikeouts for luis
castillo
see the grip paul just never gets there
and
the tails away from that left-handed
hitter second most strikeouts in a start
this year by castillo
well hit to right center akiyama
leaps into the wall shogo akiyama
robs dylan carlson a spectacular glove
that was dynamite well i mentioned the
at-bats but how about flashing the
leather out there
covering the ground and getting to that
wall winker is single the devil that
scored two and a line out to
center field and he hits this one a ton
high deep going it's out of right field
five to one reds oh jesse
carlson with a little bit too much
height on his ball
run down by kiama and wink said no this
is how you do it
in our yard that's a line drive right
there there is a time to pounce it's now
yep and the 2-0 is hit out too
deep right field it is bouncing
and over the wall for a ground rule
double so arenado
brings in goldie back-to-back doubles to
start this eighth inning cardinals have
something going and it's 5-2
the 1-1 pitch and the center and a base
hit for paul the
young that'll bring in arenado it makes
it five to three
and the tying run will come to the plate
rocket caught by suarez flipped to
second
and time double play oh did the reds
need that mike schilt knows the weight
and the momentum
of this call save big ball a lot of
moving parts here bases loaded
cardinals have drawn within a couple
popped up farmer in the grass they leave
him loaded
doolittle does the job and gets out of a
major jam to preserve a two-run lead
two outs nobody on down by
to two field tyler naquin
the reds take the series and cincinnati
has topped saint louis
in six straight games for the first time
in 18 years